how many times per week can a man cry
my negative one
after the ladies how many how many times
a week can your man cry
i think it depends like say first
exactly imagine he's lost someone
important to him like cry as much as you
want you have to get it out
but if it's like like you said like just
give us a block just give us a blunt
honest number
what's more attractive a man that can
like hold it together and be strong or a
man that's like blubbering on the floor
like crying for like weeks being
vulnerable and crying
but but you date the ass
no listen like i said it depends the
situation if it comes home and he's like
so you annoyed me at work and started
like
oh that's an ick yeah okay okay so if
you lose something he loses someone
close to him he's crying every day yeah
for two three weeks straight every
single day you're you're you're just
fine but you're doing the same thing for
two years yeah but you're a girl so like
but you're equally you're equally
attracted but she's i'm sorry
you want to screw him the same no but i
mean there's a way to deal with that
because if i i'm there for you so i'm
gonna help you get up yeah that's a long
time yeah i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to step in now because i've allowed
you one two weeks all right but no no we
need to work on this let's let's
even if i if if i was a i even i'd be
like listen bro like you need to fix up
like that
when you're tired
you had your time to move like you had
your time to like you know cry and yeah
you're still going you know what i mean
we're gonna learn how to deal with this
because there's no way i'm gonna watch
someone cry if someone's lost someone no
like every person obviously every person
here has like
different ways of dealing with it like
whether that's crying for weeks on end
or kind of like getting back to work
because everyone's doing it but like
there's a certain time where it's like
yo like like you're living like
the person's gonna be loved and
remembered you're gonna go
put flowers in the grave and light a
candle and you know just chill there and
talk to that grave you know what i mean
but like life goes on like you gotta
like move past that no matter obviously
it's gonna be hard but yeah deal with it
like the way you want to do it i don't
think there's i don't think there's a
time limit on that like for example my
friend
lost his mom um he lost his dad when he
was much younger when he was a child and
then he lost his mom and he's his only
only child like if he wanted to cry for
a whole year i get it because that was
the only person you were close to like
he has family like uncles and aunties
and stuff yeah but like we get it yeah
well i mean
like
hey there's a difference
girls get it i think girls get it but
we're just not attracted to it yeah i
was gonna say your question was are you
are you more attracted to someone who's
gonna deal with it straight away start
going gym like
like deal with it that way or
it's gonna
okay like cry a little bit
but then you're not going to be
attracted to someone that's you're going
to be more attracted to someone who's
like wow they're going out there they're
doing like i don't know like charity
marathons for whatever or they're like
they're doing something active you know
to like get over it making sure that's
still gonna like she's sitting here okay
and how you're dealing with it she's
like i get that but she's saying what's
more attractive
i think
i'll be better
i think it depends i think if you say i
think if you're saying
i'm sorry i think if you're saying
you're like yo you're good
because i think what happens is
okay now i think it depends on if
crying every day every day for however
however long it's fine
if you're not moping about if you're
still proactive so if he's still
proactive he's still doing what he needs
to do but every now and again
you know he'll catch himself thinking
about the person he lost and he cries
that's perfectly fine but if he's just
doing nothing and dedicating his you
know every waking hour to just crying
and not yeah being motivated and i can
completely understand that you know that
being a turn-off but i feel like i'm not
a woman but i feel like a woman can
still find a guy attractive if he's
crying every day but still showing the
masculine yeah
i just
i think
and this is bad this is bad but it's
just honest like i think a woman can
understand yeah but i don't think a girl
really is going to want to screw you
after she's seen you crying i just don't
think we're turning them bring them down
a bit as well if they're trying to
always cheer you up yeah it's gonna
bring you down as well a little bit yeah
and like it's not it's not fun i don't
enjoy this it's just i just think it's
how we're wired yeah like we want we
want the guy like the the men i respect
the most in my life like when i think of
them they don't cry yeah like my dad
i've seen him cry like twice there's no
one i respect more than my dad
and every time like i've seen him yeah
twice in my life
and it's much better to like i think
have like strong masculine presence and
then occasionally like when you when if
that happens now and then it's like
rather than someone that's blubbering
like or every every time something goes
wrong they're blubbering because how am
i supposed to trust you if you're like
in your feminine and like every time
something goes wrong
i guess it depends it depends on the
frequency yeah yeah if it's if if it's
all the time it's a bit
i feel like for that sort of reason as
well that's why like a lot of men they
go there's a lot more men that um commit
suicide than females yeah i think
it's it's got a lot to do with that as
well because they don't want to see
be seen vulnerable by their partner or
they don't want to
show emotions so
they let it build up by trying to be
active or do whatever rather than just
let out yeah it builds up mentally and
then they end up like killing themself
or you know being depressed or like
gets worse
so i feel like when women can
let her out they can cry whether they
could talk talk or whatever about their
problems
and i feel like it can get dealt with
better
because
they're allowed to they're allowed to by
society basically so
yeah well i think i think men should be
able to like cry and be emotional i just
think they should be able to they should
do it to other men
that's the worst nah that's that's even
wrong
like i'm just being honest like your
girl is not going to respect you like
every study that's ever studied this
ever
has has come to the conclusion that if
the girl
if if the guy cries in front of the girl
she does not respect you the same and so
like i could lie to like i could lie to
you and say oh and like pretend i'm
different
and but i'm like being honest like i i
don't think it's wise to cry in front of
your girl all the time like she's not i
mean
even
yeah like i don't know like how often
you guys cry
oh yeah let me know call actually i've
not cried in a minute i've not cried in
a minute there's nothing no no i
actually learned like the last time i've
cried i remember specifically that was
when my great grandma passed away but
the way i cried was like it was one of
those things where i walked in here and
i saw her like in the casket stuff like
that and then i just stared at her for a
minute and then i didn't like
cry but it was automatic like my tears
just started pouring out so i'm just
there with the most straightest face and
like
yeah it's like it's like you know when
you're trying to hold like you'd be
trying to be gangster be like but it's
just
automatic
you know
yeah
and that was like
six years ago
i'm gonna read the super chats really
quick okay um
my favorite donut sentience
fifty dollars come on girl
come on my god
hey
he's back
okay um again guys all of these super
chats are going towards another camera
i'm trying to get
angle here angle here if we raise 500
during this stream i think i want to i'm
sorry i'm ballparking i don't know the
exact number but it's like around 500
i'm trying to get before the end of the
month so we can afford